the Joe Rogan experience chef kuma and
dice doing die sobs oh dear friends
right other friends I know they had a
thing for awhile that's washed that was
one of the best feuds that's a good roll
radio fuses radio kids were great he
would do radio feuds on purpose but dice
would get into feuds purpose or purpose
yeah so much of it was like theater
people don't know he called me a crazy
[ __ ] he did he commits so hard remember
when he had those comics acting out some
movie that he was filming with his VHS
good never-ending dice movie by the way
he stopped and he rewind and press pause
right there and start recording from
there yes couldn't go back and forth
backwards forward backward or stop that
guy's about to bunch of no no way mid
punch this is after he had sold out like
what 300 stadiums yeah he sold out
arenas and stadiums all across the world
he was a giant superstar yeah after that
he's recording these [ __ ] weird
impromptu you made us have he made us
have characters monster Barney would
show up because you're the foreigner and
every time you show up I'm gonna give
you the evil eye but if I look back we
couldn't go on stage we'd have to do
this thing first yeah Brenna's easy was
tower to Mars was the foreigner he had
mean Bobby while we were fighting he had
us he made us come into these and like
beat each other up oh my god yeah so
ridiculous so ridiculous we would slam
each other's heads against [ __ ] but to
in that way he's like this son which are
unique like who would you say dice is
like if someone said what's dice like in
real life I'd be like what yes like you
don't know anybody like him why am I
telling you but you have to meet him we
can't understand it yeah you can't do
you don't know he's wearing he's wearing
like old Jewish lady sunglass oh yeah
enormous the glasses are enormous
his giant sweat shave up on dyeing his
hair it's all gray now yeah like said
yeah the glasses are like the Elvis they
like not rhinestones but the thick gold
goes back here to get shorter you know
legit at the gym every day so he does a
lot of videos from the gym because he
does work out a lot still here's a term
called
you know in the cage oh my god that
picture is amazing
just just rock diamonds everywhere
pictures of me look at the one above it
the upper-left that's just a glass of
does that's classic dice it was good
me Rumia me and COO Mia and Jimmy and
[ __ ] who else went with us somebody else
I went with it I went with you once to
the to the dice show Vegas you were
there too I think I'm at a different
time and you guys went oh man we all
went to the Riviera before the Riviera
close he was up in that uh the upstairs
restaurant the large room yeah dude we
had such a good time that's giant
sideburns yep look at them love them in
Wolverine but it was such a valiant
Wahlberg I know it's funny shaved the
throne even on the bottom this is my new
sideburns he's always looking for a goof
Oh always always oh no just like yeah he
gave somebody his phone and his phone
number out on radio one day he was about
to get a new phone and so on radio he
goes hey my old phone numbers he didn't
say old phone number it goes my phone
number is this and he goes give me a
call I'll talk to you and people start
talking to him on calling him he said
come come my car look it turned it on as
soon as he turned it on just arts
ringing people calling non-stop hello
yeah yeah it's me uh this is one guy
where he start calling the guy back and
then he started like bothering the guy
oh my call him at work it's just Andrew
I think I was like nice I just have to
talk to him
his dream was to talk to dice work right
now I really can't
so what kind of work you're doing right
now what is it who's there just
bothering and it's like until the guy
was like avoiding his call that would be
the thing that gets his gear spinning
that would be it I know what I want to
do
yeah like that that would be what he
wants to do he would you'd rather be the
butt of the joke or he'd have somebody
else watching him yeah classic human and
just love that all the time and it's
like even to this day he's doing it if
someone's in the back steps at the
Comedy Store and let's say you're
fabulous you're standing straight up and
I'm two steps up you can't see focus
okay so I'm two steps you're standing up
I'm standing up I'm two steps I'm on a
shtetl you're like oh nice nice to meet
you did you do that hey dice nice to
meet you oh yeah yeah that's really good
I just never looked down that's great
I just knock him down enough looked out
just like oh that's good it's always
great to meet a fan oh that's great I
think guys like that's okay sure I see
you and then he's sit down just ask if
solve we saw that god he's crazy yeah
he's always in it for the goof he's a
legit character right his message I
remember realizing at some point I
didn't have to grow up in his business
like I still had thoughts of like even
though I'm not gonna be a lawyer like
but like that's still the direction I'm
supposed to head you know it's like we
have should be distinguished yeah or
something if and change your behavior
we're gonna happen I'm gonna become an
adult and then I heard a call dice and
his answering machine was that Scott is
mid-50s right and I'm like oh maybe I
don't have to grow up maybe I could just
be like [ __ ] whatever oh look I never
changed I don't think you have to grow
up I think people will put pressure on
you because they have to grow up maybe
they're like why don't you have to grow
up enablers yeah as long as you're
paying your bills as long as you're
paying your taxes you know you're not
you know you're not a deadbeat dad keep
child abuse to a minimum
you said that is hard that as long as
you're a good person who gives a [ __ ] if
you grow up yeah what is happening what
are we doing we have a finite time here
we're deciding we want people to behave
in a certain way all you want people
just don't be an [ __ ] doesn't matter
if you grow up or not grow up yeah this
guy's like dice are having a great
[ __ ] time
it wasn't literally like one day he's
gonna die and I hope he dies in the
middle of a prank I know people don't
realize how do you make him happy that
stays dead never we're just kept waiting
that's what's the option and what's
option number two nobody's living
forever folks it's not happening this is
as good as it gets I will tell you if
dice dies on stage and you're a comic in
the area and you have to at some point
people start to realize oh [ __ ] this is
not a prank you know yeah if you get up
there and realize he's dead right you
should say okay and then stand up black
its [ __ ] gag and then just leave it
up there for a while longer
yeah see how long you keep it going he
would have wanted it that way yeah I
think so
yeah for sure yeah yeah he's nuts he's
just funny it's just a way to live he
made Norton and and and Florentine
introduced him like they go into a
Subway sandwich shop in the book
ladies and gentlemen avert your eyes the
ledger just coming in and he was like
walk in my sandwich shop
that's hilarious yeah there'll be a
great show you have just dice on the
road and someone announces him like that
everywhere he goes yeah peasants please
the legend clear the floor behind me
from his house for a year once would you
do I didn't do any cheap doses kids I
did not does his no I would never do
that
mostly I'm scared of dice he said he had
a gun in his in his desk drawer and I
was like no you don't no way you would
never have him around your kids because
I do and he said he'd bet me $200 and
I'm like you know I don't have $200 so I
can't make that bet and he goes on it
well I do and then he's all left his
thing goes don't look in there I'm like
I'm not gonna look in there you guys
don't [ __ ] look in there but I won't
and then Freddy Soto [ __ ] [ __ ]
Freddy's
[ __ ] told him I was just in the
office told him that I went into his
drawer he said I was rifling through his
drawers and dice like that's it it's a
lie who's a lie by Freddy total endives
like you're out you're banned from the
house go to bar because anymore yeah I
was rifling through his affairs which
never happened dice I never did that I
was in the room why do you think Freddy
did that well of course cuz of that
reason because he's that cuz he got me
bad he wanted to get you back yeah why
do you think Freddy would want to get
you man I think he was jealous of my
upbringing and how I had a foosball
table at home and it always bothered him
they didn't have that growing up in
Texas interesting maybe interesting I'm
not sure but the point is I never
referred those Affairs
[Applause]